foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's up my name is Samuel leads
I've helped thousands of people over the
years become financially free through
investing in property
[Music]
I'm doing a social experiment where I'm
taking a large group of people all at
once I'm training them mentoring them
and working with them to help get them
results in property
[Music]
and the goal is that they'll be able to
become financially free in one month
through property let's see how many
people we can help achieve that this is
going to be fun
[Music]
I really believe that 80 of success is
just showing up and you showed up you're
here ready to roll
[Music]
I can spend five minutes with anybody
and within five minutes
I can predict their financial future for
the rest of their life
[Music]
we're gonna be doing some exercises for
some of you guys these exercises are
going to be extremely powerful and
life-changing
[Music]
But ultimately there's only one person
who is in charge and there's only one
person who's ultimately responsible for
your life and your success and that
person is you
so what's gonna happen is today is going
to get your business plan ready today is
going to get your thermostat right then
tomorrow you're finding deals crunching
numbers learning what makes a good deal
what makes a bad deal then the deal
selling masterclass two days is going to
be how to package the deal how to find
investors how to sell to investors and
some of you will find good deals on the
deal finding Extravaganza we're going to
be selling your deals on the deal
selling masterclass
[Music]
would anybody we like to share what
their goals are and speak it out
so my name is Andre since lockdown I met
my partner when I met her she had cancer
and everything had to be put on hold and
now I want to transition from active
income to passive income
what's the goal by the end of the year
what is to happen by the end of this
year the goal by the end of this year I
like to be making four to five deals a
month and have two to three service
accommodations portfolio set up okay and
what about by the end of this week so
I've gained a good understanding and
Foundation of how property investing
works I want to be taking action and
making things happen from that knowledge
that you've shared with me and making a
few deals yeah amazing can we give a guy
a big handsome come look
I've been working in the property
industry for the last three years now
nearly three years as an estate agent
what's the goal by the end of the year
end of the A1 Equipment job okay you're
already selling deals yeah and how many
deals do you sell a month
10 20 20. let me tell you something
you're a very good estate agent but I'm
really here for a plan because I want to
create a better life for myself a life
that I don't need to take a break from
your thermostat is actually set for
quite high you're just doing the wrong
thing what you need to do is you need to
use your current skills but just
transition
if you're already selling deals in a
state agency you've probably got the
skills you just need to be doing working
in a slightly different hemisphere does
that make sense can we give her a hand
show something up
this is fun all right anybody else
well my goal for the end of this year is
To Be A Millionaire the reason why I
want to do this is I've actually been
off sick with a depression for the last
six months I'm due to return to work in
June I don't want to go go back to work
my job is
it would mean obviously the world to be
financially free it would mean not
having to go out of work and do a job
that actually is not good for my mental
health it would mean just being able to
give my family back home a lot more than
like I can get them now it would mean
probably more than anyone knows
I've promised myself if I sell it to you
by the end of June I am quitting my job
I'm not returning okay so question
what was your job that you didn't I work
and with the council I work with kids um
living care okay if I give you some
feedback of course how many of you can
see Florence has got a lot of passion
yes or no guys
a lot of passion where I think you will
fall short and struggle where you're
gonna need help is focus okay yeah I've
got ADHD there we go in the bank right
now about 800 pounds about 800 pounds
yeah and what is your net worth
don't worry it's okay I knew that you
wouldn't know your net worth yeah I knew
you had ADHD yeah because I've got ADHD
and I also knew you wouldn't have any
money in the bank yeah in fact coming
out the front Okay then come out the
front come on
come on you have ADHD as well which not
a lot of people see and I struggle a lot
to focus and which is a big thing for
which is a big thing for me so he was
able to see that so for me that that was
really incredible the passion bit a lot
of people say that about me and I am
very passionate so here's what we need
to do all right here's the goal now the
goal is this
two things number one today yeah you
need a crystal clear business plan okay
which I'm gonna make sure you have to be
a crystal gay business plan number two
tomorrow the deal fighting extravaganza
have to bring me a deal
I will okay you have to bring me
something if it's good I'll sell it and
we'll get that deal sold this week okay
can we give her a big hand
[Applause]
just because I like a bit of confidence
right now it doesn't mean that it's not
going to grow by the end of this week
and that I'm not going to be able to
achieve the things that I I I hope to
achieve I really believe so um that's
why I'm taking away that anything is
really possible that you can do anything
in a big way he's right when he was
talking about like um
your goals and stuff and I was thinking
you know maybe he's right
the the bar's not hot enough definitely
because he was talking about your um
your famous laughter your financial
famous stuff being low but what you'd
write mine is low you know what I mean
like I'm trying to make it big I'm
trying to make it better by
getting into property and you know
letting what we're learning now but
still but still it's it's set low turn
them in this is fun oh anybody else yes
go ahead stand up what's the goal my
brother uh the goal is to build a
property portfolio yes starting in the
short term with a portfolio by to let
okay um but once I've got goal though
because you you told me you told me what
the target was the targets to get two
properties but what's the goal
the goal is to build a property
portfolio
that's my goal that's a Target yeah
what's the goal
the goal this year is to buy two that's
not a goal that's a Target okay what's
the reason what's your what's your oh
the reason the reasons because I've
always worked on a job and um I don't
want my kids growing up working for
money I want to make sure that they you
know the right mindset in life and I can
crack it for them and you know make the
right Investments yeah why would you be
trying to do buy refurbish refinance
because that's going to take forever to
replace your income why would you not be
looking at for instance deal selling
look and I've seen your videos and I've
seen other people sell deals I just
can't grasp
um the whole deal selling yeah because
because you're really hard to sell to
and you have a broke thermostat yeah
maybe completely utterly broke
I might have a little bit of money
uh yeah yeah yeah
similar to this lady over here we sold
our house
um we bought it for 160 and sold it for
227 so we did require the accuracy
through that good for you and you feel
now like you've done well because you
just did a little flip made a little bit
of money got a little bit of money hit
the account recently feel like you're
doing well but you need to remember
you're not doing well you're you're
doing utterly [__]
you're hanging around the wrong people
my friend you're hanging around bums is
slightly better than your friend so you
feel like I'm doing well man I just
bought this house for 160 now it's when
it went up to this I made some good
money man no you're broke you're making
two and a half Grand a month and you
don't even enjoy it you need to
completely change your plan completely
change the thermostat
so I don't know how he'll take it I
don't know whether he'll even stick
around he might leave but I'm not here
to be anyone's friend I'm here to get
them to see results so that's why I said
what I said
I think everybody in the room has got
potential because they've invested to be
here they've put four days aside to be
with me and then they're going to get
supported throughout the month and it's
a group Financial Freedom challenge so
I'm going to push as many of them as
possible over the Finish Line my name's
Daley currently work for Tesla so
selling the electric car has been
working there for the past eight years
my name is Kylie and I thought we would
save a deposit and go at property in a
very slow way until we discover Samuel's
videos I've got a nice juicy deal at the
moment put an offer in yesterday and
just waiting for the phone calls to come
back from that to if that's accepted
then someone's going to buy that
definitely it's a decent investment
would it be easy to sell for three four
grand
probably not that easy to sell because
it's quite easy to find stuff like that
I'd like to get to a position where I'm
I'm comfortably doing three Deals a
month and that'll just give me it just
just enough so I can quit my job and
then I can focus more on the bras
because that's where my passion is I
want to buy and refurbish houses we're
both really family orientated for us
would be sort of a first-in property in
our families Sit On A New Path of a
foundation for where our family will
then grow into as well my name is Raj
today I'm basically here to to learn how
to do dual sulcin and dual packaging and
to sell onto the Right End user
basically so I had a commercial to
residential conversion a deal so we
should be taking a normal commercial
property and turn it into a residential
and then the second one is actually a x
cancel flat which is a brl and that'll
be turned into a normal residential flat
for someone
you got
ta focus on one because when you confuse
people you lose them you're confusing me
already because you're talking about
I've got this one and this and I've got
this thing and it's confusing what's the
purchase price 360 and you know what the
conversion will be
it just needs a new kitchen and bath and
how are you going to be adding value by
literally just changing the kitchen and
bathroom yeah because it's uh it's
priced in as a commercial uh commercial
price the
yeah well Samuel has seen the numbers
uh or brief briefly heard the numbers
and seen the numbers and he knows
they're bangers so I was getting
together about the end value than being
four right because if it keeps reducing
it he can't sell it and only into the
kitchen bathroom you have to sell a deal
this week there bro while you're here
man
I've got a really straightforward one as
well I mean that's a shame
another one I thought we only had one
deal that you were talking about
[Music]
honestly so far it's been an amazing
experience learned quite a lot of
valuable knowledge as well
[Music]
I will be because I know what to do and
what's that I followed the ladder
give him a hand
[Applause]
[Music]
My ultimate ultimate goal is to help
others achieve their goals financial
goals I also want to build schools in
different countries
[Music]
I want something bigger than just
working the nine to five and working for
a big company at the NHS I want to make
something that's just as impactful to my
country in Nigeria
[Music]
that's what drives me and pushes me I'm
motivates me live a motivation now I
call it discipline I'm not disciplined
enough to make sure I do this because I
don't really believe in motivation
motivation is temporary and I believe in
discipline are you feeling good yes or
no
all right so now
is crunch time baby
[Music]
[Applause]
if you go to rhyme move you're gonna
struggle to find development deals just
searching usually online
so first things first if I am in leads
my strategy is going to be a little bit
different to if I'm in Croydon
[Music]
[Applause]
looking at that it's very likely to get
planning permission
it's a good job opportunity would you
agree yes or not
look out the GDP there was three ways
what was the quickest easiest way
[__] it let's ring them there's no point
of me baffing around for an hour and a
half working out the gdv and then I
ringed up the agent and the agent says
it's sold
see I'm not spending ages doing due
diligence I'm ringing first that's what
you've got to do in this game get on the
phone get on the phone get on the phone
I'm not interested in questions right
now you learn more in doing and watching
your mind's gonna be going crazy with
questions just watch learn study and do
[Music]
this is not here's one I did earlier I
could spend all day showing you projects
I've done earlier best how you find
deals
hmm
if I'm in Watford and I'm looking for
brrs oh yeah look at this
can't help but notice
space around the house
now akua is my free deal sourcer
oh don't ring me you don't like them
they're bad to you they're good to me
[Music]
and my mum bought this house
for 150 Grand we then knock down the
garage
and inherited this little bit of land
we sold the house for 185 and made 35
Grand and we kept the land we then put
planning permission application in and
got Planning Commission accepted to
build a whole new house here we didn't
build we sold the land with the planning
for 95 Grand so we made 115 Grand
without lifting the shuttle
[Music]
see you make them work right what you
got for lunch giving you my phone number
and email so you can spot what do you
got
talk to me
way to push the value up now and I said
to a look I need at least 20 and that's
not unreasonable now she get okay he
yeah he wants proper development deals
he wants proper brass he used to put his
money out I get it imagine if I rang 35
agency accordingly did that how many
deals am I going to get I'll tell you
how many shitloads true or false guys
please could you get him to book a
viewing for me I'm a property Ambassador
and I'm looking for like a number of
properties of crowns across Manchester I
just want to book a viewing for a
property I've seen online so I looked at
the picture and I thought that's
absolutely perfect
um a quick question though
um a property of that size let's say it
was in good condition what you got yes
[Music]
just tell him oh you can do a HMO I've
looked into hmu in that area it is um
it's popular the rooms are being rented
out
you need to find out if this isn't an
article 4 area because I think this
would lend itself really nicely to a HMO
you're probably gonna get 400 pound of
room
I reckon so if you're getting 400 pound
of room and there's five rooms that's
going to be two grand
a month a grant I think it's a solid I
like that you've got a viewing on it
cool so what you need to do is you need
to find out if it's an article 4 area
and really get package it do as much
research as you can now you've got a
viewing on it all right off you go well
done
Florence's deal looks good the thing is
with Florence is I know that when she
does her first deal her confidence is
going to go through the roof and she's
going to be a machine she's just gonna
go again again again again rad just got
some crazy deals going on his problem is
he needs to focus he's speaking to that
many agents I think even in his mind
he's confused about what he's got uh
surrendered to go
um it's in a great area I use Nimbus map
to look at all the whole area is this
your best deal as in from a flip from a
flip no from any point of view from a
something that's ready to sell really
Goods is your best deal I would say is
one yeah my best daughter along with
other deal as well which was the other
deal again the throwback one the flat
where was that E3 London show me that
one but this would be a really really
cool
um rent to rent like just four that ages
said to me he'll get 1600 for this I
reckon we'll cook at 17. do a bit higher
spec so you're ready to exchange yeah
basically it's just send you a passport
over
um and I spoke to your guy on the
finance he's got to be a cash buyer yes
I
believe it needs to be cash
[Music]
yes if he's aware of another banging
deal that one goes but it's it's already
gone through um
you know when they put it through from
the highest bidder when they do subject
to bidding and they take all the bids
and yeah send it so I'm just another
deal
yes dude you need to stop confusing me
by talking about what other deals bro
I'm confusing okay you just stop being
so confusing focus on your deal is best
and really push that I like this you
know what I'm saying it's confusing man
switching I've got this thing and just
as I'm looking at it he'll throw this at
me and throw this at me that's not how
you sell bills to investors you need to
focus on one deal Get It Over The Line
Carly and Daley have got a few deals but
they need to do way more due diligence
before we think about selling them what
is this is a bro or is it by select what
is it um it could be a brr so this is
already in really good condition right
yeah so what's the vision uh the vision
is to turn it into four beds HMO and how
much did you say they'll accept uh one
two two how much would the conversion
cost which turn into a HMO do you think
I don't think it'll cost any more than
20 25.
what would it cost even that much
is that gonna get a fifth room there uh
well I was thinking about it yeah but
then you need a license then
ah okay I think that one's your best
your best of the bunch from what I've
seen
because it's nice straightforward cheap
and cheerful yeah four rooms easily no
license no planning permission really
easy no particular refurb only 122 grams
nut price down a bit rent the rooms out
to what 400 450 450. but you've got to
look at the systems the procedures the
market research the due diligence the
rules the regulations so they've got a
whole bunch more due to the reasons to
do before we can think about selling
their deals but fingers crossed
foreign
man I've given him one job which is
Booker viewing any viewing a br HMO a
rental just Booker viewing and he just
seems to have a mental shutdown I don't
know maybe I was a bit too hard on Dan
yesterday but he seems deflated you know
what you'll start you should be
packaging and selling rent to rent in
Liverpool because if you get a brr it's
gonna take you a year before you start
making money from it if you find a land
on the top of your meant to rent and you
can find something it was half decent
tomorrow we will sell it but you can
still do brl there bro but the Focus
right now has to be getting cash in the
bank because when you start getting cash
in the bank bro your confidence is gonna
go through the freaking roof so you have
one goal now and that one goal is to
find a landlord who's up for doing a
rent to rent and if you can find that
tomorrow we'll get some money in the
bank okay respect brother really what he
wants to do is be our but he needs to
start making some quick cash as well
because he's in a job he's done two and
a half Grand he's working his ass off he
needs to go full time in property and
the fastest way he's going to do that is
through deal selling and they can do brr
in the background but Dan's the fight I
need to spend a bit more time with Dan
give him a bit of a lift
foreign
how we're feeling today I'm pretty
pumped I am feeling extremely
overwhelmed
slightly tired it's been a long night
packaging the deal yeah we're feeling
really really confident with the deal
that we found today through all the
training that we've been having it's
helped us to put all the pieces of the
jigsaw puzzle together slightly finally
see the picture come together now
Central London a property for that price
why there's a property crisis and people
are looking for great deals no one buys
it I'm gonna aim to buy it myself yeah
that's how confident I am I think a big
takeaway for me was done is the new pay
effect
stop going over it stop considering it
get it sent come on let's go
I feel like I'm closer to my goals I
don't think a lot of people really
understand the level of life changing
this is for me so deals are changed not
just my life my family was I you know
there's so many people that I can impact
working with my job right
I drop young people off in a really
really what I mean terrible
accommodation this is a 16 17 year olds
part of what I'm gonna do when I when
I'm able to escape properties nice
properties for care leavers so if I'm
good at this I can source and get the
council to actually improve young
people's lives if you live in a shitty
home how are you supposed to progress in
life your home
is something that encourages you and
stuff like that you need to live in a
safe night so being able to do this I
feel like that just keeps going on my
head now I feel like I can do anything
you're not saying
bad news
Dan it's gone come on where
it's gone why
overwhelmed
I'm serious bro
oh man you know what's really annoying
about that in my mind I was thinking I'm
going to 100 make sure that he makes
money today
I said to you I said to him yesterday
bring me a deal I'll sell it I'll sell
it and you get all the money and he was
okay he was trying he was getting close
man in my mind I'm thinking if even if
I've just out till two in the morning
today I'm staying with him until they
make some money he's gone
and you know it's also interesting Dan
is the only person
in the entire room on the entire program
that didn't actually pay for his ticket
what do I always say if you don't pay
you don't pay attention
yeah yeah he's the only person that
didn't pay
and he's gone home and everybody else is
still here
wait what's funny
what's funny I'm actually really upset
should we try getting back or do we
leave him
I said we leave them all right leaving
I'm focusing on these guys man they're
actually paid and they were paying
attention
what do you make that would be what do
you think
I'm shocked did you know that you hadn't
paid to be here
he had loads of potential man I should
have met I did him a disservice by not
forcing him to pay if he had paid it
would he have left nah he'd be here
still he'd be making money today
[Music]
I'm gonna struggle with this one because
there's literally so many good deals
where's RAV with the flat in London your
deal to be fair looks sick
basically the situation is with your
deal because I know we've spoken about
it is it's worth 300 Grand it's in
London and it's just a repossession and
the bank just wants the money quickly
and is selling it and this little sword
has agreed to buy it for 210 Grand and
you've already got the memorandum of
understanding wrapped up and everything
yep ready to go all right that sounds
really good give him a hand give him a
hand all right if you want to take a
seat for a second
Florence has got a brr in Wellesley
I've never heard of that place but could
you stand up did you want to just tell
us about the deal so the properties um
for offer over 200 but I think I can get
it for 190. when you say you think you
can get it for 190. I said agent um is
it is the owner open for pro offers and
if I was to put in an offer of one line
to potentially it says anything is
possible okay so Matt I'd be going in at
180. I've seen the property and when you
it's an interesting thing when Flo came
to me she said this is a HMR and it
looked to be honest like a banging HMO
but the problem was I said to flow I
said is it in an article four and it is
in an article form but it only needs
about 25 Grand spending on it and what's
the end value around 282.90 could even
be worth more yeah yeah okay good I like
that a lot I like that deal
Carly and daily where you guys at we
found a property up in Warrington which
is uh not in an article 4 area it's a
two Bay Terrace it can be easily
converted into a four bed HML the vendor
was looking for originally 140. I put an
offering of 110. he refused it and he's
come back with uh one two two how much
for the room
uh large double rooms will rent for 500.
okay smaller rooms will be 450. can you
pull out your money at the end if you
refinanced it there'll still be 12 000
left in okay so you're only leaving 12
grand left in the deal yeah nice and
then you've got a nice high red that's
good
so this is where things get interested
now when I package their deals I want
you to learn from it and then I want you
to package your deals and the best way
to teach you is to show you is just show
you so that's what I'm gonna do right
now so
I'm gonna go
firstly I'm going to go to my CRM system
I could send an email
to everybody that's bought from me
before
or everyone that's cold or everyone
that's hot but right now I'm going to
send the email to
everybody
so this now look at this
149 000 people I'm going to send an
email to them all at once
I've had a lot of people texting me as
you can see same Chloe said this one
this one this one I'm gonna call them
back in the order that they text me yes
how's it going my friend
I've got this deal in London you know
what London's like it's rare to get
bangers in London it needs a little bit
of work nothing much the value of it is
is around 300 000 so it's a bit of a
banger the only catch the agent that
said that they wanted they wanted to
complete in the next sort of like four
to six weeks so it would need to be
bridging cash the moment I have 150 000
ready to go probably I need to help
maybe but bridging alone you know that
app is what I'm thinking is we can
reserve it for you
um so the the fees three thousand so I
mean how what's the best way
thank god with me right now
[Applause]
hello it's Samuel I'm just responding to
your text message about the property in
Warrington this particular property
um yeah it's basically like a cheap and
cheerful HMO it's just outside article
four you wouldn't need a license because
it's not five bed the rooms themselves
two of them are 450 as the rent and two
of them 500 because two of them are a
bit smaller two of them but they're all
but they're all good sized rooms there's
quite a big house the settler was is
just quite motivated and we've got it
all wrapped up at 122 000 so we've got a
good size the Red's good once the
problem is converted I think it would
probably be worth sort of close to a
closer to around 180.
straight to you ping the money over then
text me once you've pinned it over and
then boom we'll arrange a zoom golf when
you get back from your gig
nice one thank you bye-bye
done
I've got good news
got bad news
bad news is the property that you
messaged me about unfortunately has sold
the good news is that I've got another
one which I think is even better it's in
merseyside but it's like the nice side
of merseyside I've got connections to a
couple of housing associations you're
looking about 300 pounds of room but
even as a single that you're talking
about 1500 pounds the end value I think
this house once it's done up it's gonna
be worth I've put 295 but I think that's
quite conservative so to get the ball
rolling it would be a three thousand
pounds uh reservation fee so how would
you like to how would you like to pay uh
bank card I think you're gonna be really
happy because it's a it's a banger to be
honest so
exactly what can I say
all right I'll get that thing over right
now my friend and just drop me a text as
soon as you paid all right yep
all right appreciate it bye-bye
there we go well done
hopefully I've sold my first deal I'm
literally very much overwhelmed right
now
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
selling properties probably even one of
the most incredible thing I've ever felt
just the experiences has been it's just
been insane
um literally showed me how how fast like
deals can be sold it's also elevated my
belief as well I know what just happened
we just sold our first deal so the first
deal yeah I feel boozing yeah a bit a
bit overwhelmed and it's still like okay
what's next yeah yeah let's go give us
the next steps but I know this is out in
Boys in that sensation you get when you
just make a sale it's just unbelievable
you see it you see it you see it we've
seen one is Wednesday I've watched
everything there you go oh that close we
said it at Wheels but that's us so he's
just been a helpful since the whole
process to be honest with you for me
probably after this I'm gonna go off and
actually even be way much more better
than actually I was even to get this
deal yeah we wrote down everywhere they
said every question yeah yeah I think
Sam has also shown like every
conversation is different sometimes you
have to be faster sometimes you have to
explain
something you have to listen so he's got
different approaches I took a lot of
notes as well yeah yeah I like how quick
Punchy to the pointy was you know
sharing the vision as well to the to the
investor getting the invested on board
with that idea as well and selling it
that way perfect this means a lot to me
it means absolutely the world it means
that
I can actually live a job that it has
made me ill that I'm literally petrified
to go back to
and I was like I can even read my
manager tomorrow and say like look June
is coming up I don't think I'm coming
back you know I don't know it I don't
think I'm not coming back next
um I still have models the process works
so I believe that now look into the
academy as well I think the academy is
really really powerful next at vrr
ultimate goal land and our own
development oh we're skipping the essays
now are we just they're skipping up
maybe some rent to rent as well yeah I
love it yeah yeah yeah a lot of people
like it's one deal but that one deal
with the world one deal it's like I feel
like I won the lottery
[Music]
foreign